en déplacement pendant trois jours à la
réunion christelle du boss secrétaire
d'état auprès de la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé et olivier
noblecourt déléguée interministérielle à
la prévention et à la lutte contre la
pauvreté ont rencontré les partenaires
associatifs et institutionnels tous
acteurs de la solidarité
les travaux menés vise à mettre en
oeuvre la nouvelle stratégie de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté à la réunion un nouveau
dispositif est inaugurée ici à la caisse
d'allocations familiales du chaudron il
s'agit du premier point conseil budget
il n'y a pas de lieu labellisés sur
lesquels je suis une famille j'ai une
difficulté avec ressources en ressort
une difficulté financière vers qui je me
retourne et donc ces points conseils
budget labellisé 460 territoire 5 pour
la réunion et a rappelé que le premier
que j'inaugure est aujourd'hui est le
premier de tout le territoire national
trouver des conseils personnalisés pour
la gestion de son budget pouvoir faire
face à une situation financière
difficile ces points conseils budget
orienteront les familles en situation de
surendettement ont 165 familles sont
aujourd'hui en situation de
surendettement pour une moyenne de 35
mille euros par famille puisque le total
du surendettement à la réunion pour le
moment de près les dossiers qu'on
connaît 7,35 millions le déplacement de
cette délégation interministérielle vise
à rédiger la feuille de route de la
stratégie de prévention et de lutte
contre la pauvreté sur le territoire les
chantiers prioritaires ont été présentés
par les rapporteurs et les acteurs
politiques car le département c'est quoi
c'est d'abord accompagné la création
d'activité
accompagner les familles en grande
difficulté lutter contre l'échec
scolaire travailler pour une politique
de logement adapté à la réunion plus de
logements sociaux plus de logements
intermédiaires donc lutter contre les
addictions
donc tout cela ce sont des fiches
actions que nous mettons en place et
cette visite ministérielle
elle s'inscrit dans ce cadre là nous
sommes en plein dans l'action au service
des réunionnaises et des réunionnais
[Musique]